[BAND'S INTRODUCTION
IN SPANISH]
[MUSIC - JANE'S ADDICTION,
"STOP"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - JANE'S ADDICTION,
"AIN'T NO RIGHT"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - JANE'S ADDICTION,
"END TO THE LIES']
[APPLAUSE]
PERRY FARRELL: Welcome
to Googlepalooza!
Well, we've been a fan of
Google's for a long time,
right, Dave Navarro?
DAVE NAVARRO: You
got that right.
Hell, yeah.
PERRY FARRELL: And as I see
tonight, you've been a fan of
Jane's Addiction.
So thank you.
It's nice to meet you all.
I don't know what we got paid
here, we just did it just
because, right?
[MUSIC - JANE'S ADDICTION,
"JUST BECAUSE"]
PERRY FARRELL: Thank
you, Google.
Thank you, Google.
[MUSIC - JANE'S ADDICTION,
"JUST BECAUSE"]
[APPLAUSE]
PERRY FARRELL: Oh, it's
like a family reunion.
Your applause is deafening.
It's so appreciated.
When I go home tonight and I put
that computer on my dick,
I will applaud you, too.
OK?
All right.
Boom, boom, boom.
[MUSIC - JANE'S ADDICTION,
"TED, JUST ADMIT IT"]
PERRY FARRELL: Oh, Dave just
said he saw a really cute girl
in the crowd.
He likes to point
them out to me.
If you want Dave Navarro
tonight, raise your hand.
[LAUGHS]
You're fucking with me.
Well tough shit, he's coming
with me tonight.
[MUSIC - JANE'S ADDICTION,
"TED, JUST ADMIT IT"]
[APPLAUSE]
PERRY FARRELL: Just so
you know, that is
the sound of my bedroom.
I love being in my bedroom.
I can't wait to get there.
And even when I wake up,
I look at the clock.
I say when is it time to
get back to my bedroom?
What about you?
Now, I hear you can find some
great internet porn on Google.
Is that true?
AUDIENCE: [CHEERS]
PERRY FARRELL: Bet you can't
find me there though.
I'm in my bedroom.
Now I have a number
in my head.
And I'm willing to put a camera
there and take one of
you with me.
But that number is
like $25 billion.
And I know you've
got the money.
Think about it.
We'll talk about it
after the show.
All right, $20 billion.
That's it.
That's my final offer.
[MUSIC - JANE'S ADDICTION,
"BEEN CAUGHT STEALING"]
[APPLAUSE]
PERRY FARRELL: Never in history
has there been such
resounding applause for
a group of thieves.
But it's OK, we all need
forgiveness, right, Google?
You Google bad guys out
there, are you?
AUDIENCE: How about
"Superhero?"
PERRY FARRELL: [LAUGHS].
Don't leave me hanging, bro.
AUDIENCE: Right on, Perry!
Right on, bro!
PERRY FARRELL: Bam!
You like my superhero gloves?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
PERRY FARRELL: Well,
so we live in LA.
You all live up in
San Francisco.
I taught my wife today,
don't call it Frisco.
It's just common knowledge.
They don't like it, and
they don't know why.
They don't know why.
Don't do it.
Don't test them.
We share things.
We share a mountain.
We share an ocean.
Are you ready to do this?
[MUSIC - JANE'S ADDICTION,
"MOUNTAIN SONG"]
[APPLAUSE]
PERRY FARRELL: So I've
got an idea.
DAVE NAVARRO: No way!
PERRY FARRELL: Yep, I
got a great idea.
Well, they had the Mormons--
why not the Googlites?
We can kind of attach ourselves
to religion.
We'll think of something and
somebody can find something
online that says we're
the prophets.
Think about it.
Think about the money.
I'm thinking about
the money still.
I haven't said no.
Mr. Navarro, are you talking
in class again?
DAVE NAVARRO: Yes I am.
PERRY FARRELL: To
girls, I see.
DAVE NAVARRO: Yes I am.
PERRY FARRELL: Mr. Navarro, I'm
going to expel you again
from class.
DAVE NAVARRO: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
That'll be the day.
PERRY FARRELL: He was
never expelled.
I'm only kidding.
He was an exemplary student.
He excelled in basketball
and mathematics--
and chicks.
And then, guitar.
And he got great grades
with electric guitar.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [CHEERS]
PERRY FARRELL: And that's
when I met him.
And I said, I'd like
to follow you.
I, too, am a fisherman
of chicks.
I know these people--
the Googlites.
It will take us 20 years
to get there.
[MUSIC, JANE'S ADDICTION,
"JANE SAYS"]
PERRY FARRELL: Thank you!
[APPLAUSE]
PERRY FARRELL: All right!
Googlites, where are
we going to set up?
San Francisco or LA?
Where do you think?
AUDIENCE: San Francisco!